[Music]
how's your weho sets my wheels oh thanks
for asking dude yeah no the the show was
good
um nice Zach is referring
to my little drop-in set at The Improv
that was [__] awesome so I I dm'd
Noelle and you got the impression that I
wanted to go to your set well the way
you phrased it no no no no you know what
I take your side because he DMs like
that yeah he DMs like that yeah he goes
he goes oh I can't DM oh excited yeah
it's so cool I emojis
[Laughter]
oh right by my house
if that doesn't sound like give me
tickets that sounds like
sounds like they come and walk over like
it's so convenient yeah all right by my
house
I'm just excited that you were in my
area
lives in L.A he's like I haven't seen
him in Rio in the in the Hollywood right
by my house yeah
I never see this guy right by my house
so I was like if you want to come by
after you know you can come through
before I could come by the club after we
didn't go to your house after you know
it was right there I thought maybe you
could just walk down he's tired you know
yeah I thought you know it's easy peasy
yeah easy transition and I responded I
said oh dude I give you tickets it was
not my show so I don't I don't think I
can like just yeah my boy's coming
and uh I felt bad and I immediately did
the thing I just did now I was like no
no I didn't mean that at all good yeah
all good that's cool I'll stay in my
house that's fine let me read my actual
response that's what I said yeah yeah
yeah he actually yeah
well you couldn't because it was sold
out but
first first DM was right by my house
exclamation mark LMAO uh not my show so
I can't offer tickets oh no it's all
good
just haven't seen you perform there
before so I got it excited
yeah you obviously wanted to go
with that emoji and then I said go crush
it with a fist you know because I can't
be there yeah
yeah
you guys are in The Green Room like wait
did you just get the same like yeah
Nikki Glazer right by my house
dude I don't know you
how are you guys doing good thank you
for the new set or a new Cabana yeah I
like I like that um you guys are talking
more about you yes yeah we're talking
about our day-to-day I think that's good
I think you guys got to get as mundane
as possible because I think people know
you're funny but I think people need to
know
I think people need to know the real the
real Zach like this is the real Zach
look at this hat look at this dumb hat
yeah I brought it on for comments today
yeah
so if you want to write a comment
I'm here for that well this is a this is
a format that people just listen to it's
a really good
[Laughter]
that's good yeah but we're uh we're
getting into uh the sports was obviously
a difficult aspect of you know we had to
talk about every sport and then people
were missing out on like what are you
talking about my sport yeah so now we're
just talking about our lives and people
are relating way better yeah yeah and
come out of pocket stuff yeah yeah
that's the thing people don't know about
you you're very out of pocket I'm doing
my best but so uh we had Drew good on
it'll come out um whenever but
um I was telling him like I've been I'm
becoming like way more open on the Pod
and like I'm trying to like Reign it in
because I've we've gotten comments for
like Zach's getting weird
like he's getting too relaxed I think
people need to know that you're weird
and people need to know that Zach this
is this is how this is the type of guy
Zach is all right
you may have just
come off of
um maybe like a a weird surgery you know
let's say you're a hefty guy and
maybe you you're the presentation of
your male chest you weren't too happy
with it so maybe you went and you got
some type of procedure to reduce it
the next time we gotta look at you and
be like do your boobs reduced
and then you're like
I did exactly oh cool what are we eating
or he would say I would never do that
yeah he thinks about himself somehow no
I think the worst thing I've ever done
was uh I went I was driving home in my
hometown sorry I'm just imagining you
going to like a [__] make a wish and
you're like oh you're sick
and
and the security guard uh it was a black
security guard and I was driving up and
I commented I was like oh uh did you get
a haircut and she said like oh no I just
changed my weave and I was like oh nice
nice and then I drove away I was like I
don't know if that was a good thing or a
bad thing I was just trying to
compliment her on her new hair and say
hey your hair looks good I should have
done that I said don't question them the
thing is you question I said did you get
a haircut
the worst one where were you guys eating
with your uh in the bay with the dad and
the baby this is [__] terrible oh uh
when I was a server no no remember you
were like you basically told a dad who
just had a baby that he gave it up on
life essentially I said that yeah
did I really say that yes bro that was
like the gist of it oh yes can we frame
the [__] story a little bit better
yes that was the story no I said uh so
it's my hometown friend we were friends
for a while and uh my big fear is when
me me and tats are having a kid is like
uh I'm gonna get like out of shape and
like all my my ambitions and stuff are
on the back burner and stuff like that
so my friend uh we're at Chili's
and uh we were sitting that's on his hat
for everyone listening chilling he's on
his hat it says I got wasted at Chili's
so the mom was hold on we gotta let the
audio listeners laugh their ass off for
a second thanks they're gonna need them
up
they're punching their steering wheel
right now one of them is that Chili's
conveniently listening to this
[__] the comments I was driving for I
think they've laughed it off and I'll go
ahead so the mom is there the husband's
there tosses there and the baby and uh I
was like so like now that you guys have
a kid like
what is this like it like is there you
guys like
it's just like
because I was so like they're again best
friends of mine like I would I'm open
with them and I was just like so like is
this what me and tots have to look
forward to like oh my god well tell me
about the fact about the like the weight
thing I was like so uh do you like not
work out anymore oh my God you're the
funniest person on Earth you are so cute
the thing is serious that's the problem
yeah it's like hysterical
serious I could just frame my questions
a little bit better yeah but don't just
keep going I think I think you actually
need to double down and I think this is
who you need to be always okay yeah you
you'll become the funniest podcaster out
right now if you ask hard-hitting mean
ass questions but innocently hard hit
and mean innocence that's Zack dude it
was also funny because he just put in
his order the triple Dipper and he got a
large beer oh my [__] god man and so
I asked the questions after he ordered
and I was like just look at it are you
like not like what's your workout habits
now you just like not work out oh my God
Zach that's right out of a movie yo get
the triple Dipper in a large beer [__]
it right so what's up you don't work out
anymore
you like gave up a life is it is this it
like you're just this is this this is
what we have to look forward to honey I
use a bad idea I told you let's go let's
go by Plan B now my 21st birthday so I
never like drinking in my family was
like taboo right like it was like that I
was gonna tell my mom I'm like hey I'm
gonna start like drinking I was gonna
have like a very serious conversation
with her
before like we all went out and stuff
and we're all sitting at the dinner
table and I invite Zach so it's me my
sister my mom and Zach very intimate
dinner right we're all eating my mom
made like some amazing food in the
middle of the dinner is actually like so
what's up are we gonna get [__] up
after this
this is my mom who's like like religious
like hardcore at the time at the time
she's a little bit more Progressive now
yeah but and then he we're like I was
like giving him the eye whatever right
and he's like what we're not We're not
gonna drink it's your 21st birthday bro
you gotta drink and then my sister and
me were kicking him under the [__]
table get this my mom goes upstairs
starts crying yeah
I don't know where you want me to go
from here real true story
yeah I just wanted to party no I'm sorry
Wally that's hilarious
that's hilarious
yeah thank you for giving me this
platform though of course yeah you're
really setting setting this up for
Success no I think I think
you're a menace and people should know
because that's the real funny part about
Zach Fiona but I'm a
I'm a menace yeah
like a get wasted that Chili's hat kind
of Menace yeah